we're back on Startalk radio and I'm
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
astrophysicist with the American Museum
of Natural History here in New York City
and I'm with Eugene Mirman Eugene you're
in our cosmic queries part yes I am
and you're my question man and I haven't
haven't seen any of these questions in
advance you know call them from the
internet for us thanks yes you're very
welcome
you're very welcome so what do you guys
I'm using this I'm an intern trying to
get a PhD um here's a question uh from
Heidi the existence of time if not now
when
dear dr. Tyson to me quest wait how was
the subject header
yeah the questions question actually I
don't think it's too long we'll run out
of time before I read it but I'm just
sue me questioning the existence of time
intuitively makes sense perhaps because
I have a difficulty with tracking time
or laying this is too long anyway the
point is I think the question is time I
think just like how does time work and
what is it why why do we use time is
time something that's man-made or is it
an actual yeah well we use the vibrator
okay let me let me handle that bit of it
yeah
so our reckoning of time exists only
because we have things that repeat in
some interval so ultimately the things
that repeat are vibrations in the
transition of hyperfine transition in a
cesium atom yes what this comes in to do
new this of course I mean tell point
point point out a five-year-old who
doesn't I dare you and so these are
vibrations they're they repeat our the
earliest time reckoning were empowered
by astronomers and we kept track my my
my cultural ancestors yet track of the
rotation of the earth so there was a day
they were sort of what a week would be
which were the quarter phases of the
moon you have the month named after the
moon you have the time the repeating
cycle of the seasons we call that a year
everything so the reckoning of time
always involves something that repeats
so whether or not we're here to observe
it whether or not you feel like a long
time is past versus a short time
psychologically right and reckon time
independent of your psychological state
and
so making it a observe up making time
time is an observable quantity now
drying can vary according to relativity
right and but that has nothing to do
with your psychology is right nothing to
do with your your physiology it has to
do with the physics of the universe
where I can send you on a trip and your
time would take more slowly writing it
with for me and it's not just the
mechanics of your watch is every
biomechanical feature of your body right
so if I flew at Lightspeed by a giant
object like the Sun I would go back into
I don't know
and so we I'm Stein is famously quoted
as time is invented to make motion look
simple and so there's a clever sort of
way to think about it but I think and
time-travel stories make for fertile
science fiction yes telling and but
other than that I mean it's it's a term
in an equation that allows you to look
localize something on a world line and a
world line is where you are in space and
where you are in time to think about it
more deeply than just a coordinate I
think is unnecessary you have never been
at a place except for at a time and
you've never existed at a time except at
a place the two go together you never
made an appointment was all see you at
3:00 so you don't think of me and
someone who walks through time no I
direct should I choose what I see well
art we are prisoners in the present not
in the eternal transition between our
past in our future Oh naive Neil it's
existed in all time uh yes time word yes
all right there's another question
here's an